obviously rich off pints we know what
that's about
uh
do you still sip is that something you
still participate in nah man i'm from my
own i don't think y'all sibling [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
i said water man i was gonna say cause
like i do feel like the tide is turning
to where at the very least
sip and lean
isn't
promoted and glorified as much as it was
as to where you know three four five
years ago if a rapper sipped lean you
would know about it
back then like that [ __ ] a drug that
[ __ ] is addicting i've really been
addicted to that [ __ ] like i don't
withdraw from that [ __ ]
you feel me like i don't withdraw it
around my old lady but felling that [ __ ]
was embarrassing you heard like that
[ __ ] of drugs i don't suggest nobody's
dreaming it ain't nothing cool about we
rap about it we rappers we hypocrites
[ __ ] i know i'm hypocrite yeah because
i don't suggest [ __ ] do a lot of [ __ ]
that i talk about but i rap about what
i've seen what you live what i live and
what i've seen others do you know i just
don't say who i seen did it you heard
like this [ __ ] be all past tense or at
this point i feel like i'm speaking for
i tell stories i tell stories that's
that's made up because i feel like i'm
speaking for people that's out there
living that [ __ ] but one thing about me
i'm always tell i'm gonna speak when i
rap i'll make songs every time i talk
and it seemed like i'm glorified some uh
some some negative [ __ ] i'ma always
speak on the consequences that come with
that [ __ ] yeah i've been in the feds
i've been in prison i know what kind of
ain't no win win what what were the
charges why'd you go to the
feds with a gun
[ __ ] well you're on a probation or
something and no just i'm a felon so
it's called felony possession
that's crazy i don't know like no major
indictment i had a one-man kind of
diamond one nobody on my indictment
wouldn't
know [ __ ] like that